alors un autre lieu habité c'est un lieu
tout à fait lectronique peut-être
qu'auparavant alors venu m'entraîner
contrevient deux albums des [ __ ]
vertes le 1er octobre il a mouché est
deuxième avec famille nombreuse et en
fait on a un troisième c'est l'album de
remy cas vraiment très très bien qu'on
connaît pas vraiment et le peuple de
l'ambiance william orbit pour d'en
parler de semaine dernière a remixé zobi
la mouche et c'est parfait avec 103 bpm
à peine sans toi battements par minute
et je suis là est vraiment bien et pas
assez connu voilà que j'ai vu il ya 151
5 indépendance les oiseaux dans les
rêves ça c'est surprenant premier voile
avoir oublié les rêves cette semaine
pour parler j'ai déjà disait d'un lieu
tout est fait familiers maintenant qui
est une une des première autoroute de
l'information comme on dit dans les
grands magazines sans fait on essayait
de premiers pas sur le trône de
l'information ce que le tour de
l'information c'est un petit peu plus
tard dans 10 ou 15 ans quand même un
beaucoup plus compliqué aussi sa série
c'est le réseau internet
alors le minitel vous voyez ce que c'est
oui c'est quoi internet exact le minitel
séparées sauf que ce mondial a lancé le
réseau de tous les réseaux vous brancher
sur internet vous pouvez communiquer
avec tous les ordinateurs du monde mais
vous vous branchez comme il faut faire
pour se plonger réponse brochet c'est
facile c'est payant donc à ce que vos
ordinateurs
un ordinateur à pc ou un mac il faut un
modem on est une petite boîte genre de
téléphone cela coûte 1500 ou 2000 froide
occasion de jouer avec l'eau mais quel
plaisir
oui c'est une petite boîte qui permet de
communiquer avec mon ordinateur il faut
une ligne téléphonique ça tout le monde
en a il faut évidemment un abonnement
revient d'abonnés aujourd'hui dans le
monde km 1 millions de connectés avec 40
millions de personnes vous pouvez poser
une question sur internet vous posez une
même question à 40 millions de connectés
mais vous avez l'expérience là alors il
est alors question paulus et le
responsable d'une association à paris
qui s'appelle fdn petite visite
l'idée d'internet
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas d'autres
outils qui existent vraiment aussi
efficace et aussi pratique que
l'internet
vraiment pratique l'internet les 40
millions de connectés s'échangent des
petites recettes de cuisine par exemple
la luigi de venise répond à bruno de
paris qui lui demandait la vraie recette
traditionnelle de la polenta sur
internet les enfants parlent nos enfants
ici un petit gars de coude aux
etats-unis cherchent un correspondant en
france ce service appel qu'à 12 550
écoles américaines s'y sont connectées
une seule en france sur internet
les citoyens du monde électronique
débattent toute la journée
là un jeune californien participe à un
forum sur le sida et raconte sa propre
expérience
les monomaniaques se réunissent dans les
clubs virtuel très fermé pour parler de
culte là un fou furieux propose la liste
de tous les cinémas du monde qui
projette le rocky horror picture show en
france au studio galande à paris
maintenant passons aux choses sérieuses
les messageries érotique avec les images
en bonus il paraît que ça fait un tabac
aux usa si je comprends qu'on peut pas
montrer ce que j'ai bloqué le large
donc ça veut dire ça marche pas tous les
cours on peut pas en france sur les
serveurs français peut pas accéder aux
messageries érotique envie que ça
n'intéressait personne n'est parti pour
les états unis certainement les peuvent
heureusement obsédé mais ça va on
aimerait voir ce qui s'y passe en tout
cas aux états unis 50% déconnecter un
sont derrière leur ordinateur et tape au
dessus de messagerie érotique 50% des
déconnecté d'internet ont vraiment des
trucs très rigolo qui se passe en ce
moment il ya un petit groupe aux petits
services qu'a pris toutes les toutes les
têtes des animateurs de télé aux états
unis il ya près d'un autre côté des
images de cinéma pour nous ils ont fait
des collages des images animées et on
vous présentera bientôt mais il ya perdu
qu un thème sur internet il ya trois
types de services est des bases de
données et des échanges entre les
universités les étudiants et les
chercheurs sas et c'est plutôt sérieux
et des news room cette espèce de gros
cons puces sur la politique la culture
beaucoup la philosophie la musique
l'espoir est là il ya aussi les mailing
list et me disent ils mais ces derniers
les listes de bresse oui c'est des
petits services de venir en france avec
un des petits forum c'est des petits
forum et on peut trouver pendant que je
vous ai trouvé des petits trucs
il ya kundera liste par exemple c'est un
service ou des admirateurs de comptes
grâce réunissent alors ils s'échangent
des idées que l'état vienne combien ils
font des débats ils peuvent retrouver
tous les papiers qui a écrit milan
kundera dans la presse internationale à
ses frais est-ce que c'est pas ça va ça
va être cette fois déjà et envoi de
piratage sur un truc alors c'est un peu
s'il ya un problème avec le gouvernement
américain en ce moment ce qui étonnant
parce que les deux plus grands
supporters d'internet s'appelle al gore
et bill clinton est un problème parce
que évidemment un tel champ d'expression
libre ça fait peur et il ya des
débordements est ce qu'on appelle des
crackers et des criminels de réseaux
anglais c'est un truc anglais aux
dépenses atrium eric avec la percée des
criminels des réseaux des hors la loi il
faut des virus partons qui sont pas très
gentils
alors du coup ce qu'on appelle les cyber
punk désole bernard les libertaires des
on n'est pas trop beau les propos ils
ont créé un nouveau langage câble est
codé pour emmerder en gros il implique
des réseaux et ça donne ça regardez ça
c'est ce qu'on trouve en ce moment c'est
à l'envers c'est comme ça c'est moche ça
change tout et oui ça surtout ses
seconds tours en ce moment sur internet
ça veut dire en gros match faire [ __ ]
d'accord c'est vrai que c'est un
investissement à au départ donc on peut
faire un apprentissage sur ligne tels
les deux serveurs sunnite et qui donne
accès à certains services d'internet csn
pour s'habituer pour s'habituer ses 36
15 teaser ter le deuxième c'est 36 14 1
7 8 de 7,03 gris trois mois ce sera son
unique sera donné ce sera voilé sera
limité les pilosités s'étaient inscrits
par le groupe à relier donc je pense
qu'on ait le temps de de le voir très
bien une ou deux adresses rapidement
poursuit pour ceux qui veulent sortir ce
soir ou demain soir au début de semaine
l'a très vite la fête de la semaine ça
se passe à calais à calais depuis
vendredi c'est le délire total se
termine le samedi 7 mai j'ai pas
d'engrais ça vous donne et il vous
suffit de déballer les reverra le tunnel
un oui ben wallace et pour fêter ça vous
venez la fête est partout et en plus
elle est gratuite des concerts
classiques des concerts de rap de la
danse les royal de luxe
des visites guidées doux dingues dans la
ville de la poésie tout ça se passe dans
la rue et 5 gratuit
a marseille le rendez vous est à
marseille dans un énoncé national du
16ème siècle
ça s'appelle le trolleybus et ce sont
cinq scènes différentes de discothèque
une salle de concert le groupe black
mariani sera vendredi une galerie d'art
et une cave à vin qui se transforme
chaque fois en boudina merci l'europe
merci on peut vous écrit directement
jetés sur format de bonnes adresses